Wisecrack Michael here today.
We're looking at a cartoon after our own hearts show,
the combined silver discussions of philosophy with zombie hordes Paris at a
clown, spiders and magic wielding fishermen. Netflix is the midnight gospel,
a co-production of comedian Duncan, Trussell and adventure time creator,
Pendleton ward,
the midnight gospel combines audio clips from Trussell's long running podcasts.
The Duncan Trussell family hour with Ward's signature visual storytelling to
create a one of a kind animated series. It is equal parts, trippy, hilarious,
and terrifying. But is the show just a compendium of shower,
thoughts to help your furlough go down easier?
Or is it a legitimate dive into quote unquote real philosophy to find out we're
going to focus on one specific aspect of the show. If you've seen it already,
you might have noticed one of Trussell's favorite subjects popping up repeatedly.
In Buddhism. The idea is all of those mental, uh, forms.
Analysis. Yeah, that's right. Buddhism.
The midnight gospel asks us to consider what are the implications of Buddhist
philosophy for people going about their everyday lives?
Should you become a societal dropout,
just like the protagonist Clancy or is there more to life than just micro dosing
and doing original magic? Well, we're about to find out, so select your avatars,
merged with their simulators and follow us as we rocket into this wisecrack
edition on the midnight gospel, deep or dump as always spoilers ahead.
And now a quick recap,
the plot of the midnight gospel and so far is the show about Yanik multi-verse
simulators can be said to have a plot centers on Clancy, a music loving burnout,
living in a trailer on the chromatic ribbon on the ribbon Clancy and other
simulation farmers spend their day shoving their heads into the affirmation.
Volvo matrices,
hoping to collect profitable artifacts or marketable experiences from the
multi-verse within Clancy.
For instance uses his trips to gather content for his pet project,
a space cast with a single subscriber.
My one subscriber her not Jensen. I live for you.
You're the reason I wake up in the morning with a smile on my face.
Clancy space.
CAS takes the form of interviews with subjects from wacky dine worlds,
usually centered around topics such as Eastern philosophy,
the occult or anything else worthy of a Keanu Reeves
said conversations use repurposed audio from Trussell's actual interviews with
people like Dr. Drew Pinsky and Anne Lamott from the beginning Clancy
prioritizes thinking about and discussing these big ideas over more practical
concerns,
such as problems in his personal life or the day-to-day operations of his
simulator on an admittedly simulated planet, overrun by zombies. For instance,
he is so unconcerned with what's going on around him,
that he continues to talk about the positive benefits of mindfulness meditation.
While the man is eaten alive in front of his pregnant wife.
They say,
look at it as though you're sitting in a forest and you're getting to watch a
rare animal walking out and the clearing.
Clancy avoids mundane tasks like reading the instruction manual for your
simulator,
dismissing them as distractions from his contemplation of the deeper truths of
existence.
Good morning, master, did you get a chance to read the universe simulator FAQ?
I left in your inbox. Nope.
Specifically Clancy through his passing familiarity with Eastern religious
traditions has come to believe that the material world is unimportant or even
illusion.
And then you become pure awareness.
And the concept is that is what we really are in that this entire material
universe, including our body is kind of [inaudible].
I can't say it. And now I'm in a logical phenomenological field of phenomena.
I feel the phenomenon being encapsulated within.
Simply Clancy is saying the tangible universe that we can see, hear touch,
et cetera, is just an imperfect manifestation of a more fundamental reality,
accessible through consciousness, altering practices like meditation, ritual,
plants, medicine, and so on.
Therefore the material world can and ought to be ignored avoided,
or ideally transcended everyday life with its bills,
neighbors and absurd laws.
Isn't the full experience of divinity enlightenment or whatever you want to call
it. Therefore it's crap.
So here's the question are Clancy's thoughts on Eastern religious philosophy
deep or more like the inane ramblings of someone who just escaped their first
Allen watch YouTube rabbit hole to answer that question and we need to ask,
does Clancy's line of reasoning fit within a Buddhist context that is,
do his beliefs hold water among Buddhist philosophers with a smidge more
experience? Well, yes and no.
Let's start with the idea that the world is unimportant and illusory.
According to the Dalai Lama, this is somewhat correct,
but only half the picture when it comes to living by the tenants of Buddhism in
mind science,
a collection of essays and dialogues the Dalai Lama contends that there are two
levels of truth in the Buddhist worldview. One,
an ultimate truth subscribed to by Clancy and your stoner roommate,
which acknowledges the emptiness of and impermanence among all things and to a
relative truth.
Having to do with the facts of existence as they relate to our daily lives,
both of these truths are equally important to living a good life.
At least within the particular version of Tibetan Buddhism,
the Dalai Lama represents the relative world with all its disappointments
frustrations and heartaches is not merely some illusion to be seen through.
This is Contra Clancy who tries to sidestep the problems of the material world
by fleeing to some supposedly higher plane of existence.
The Dalai Lama accepts the reality,
not only of the subjective world of the mind,
but also of the external objects of the physical world. In other words,
while the mind blowing cosmic insights gained through meditation and or study in
the Buddhist tradition are all well and good. They are not an excuse to golf,
to a trailer somewhere and abandoned one's responsibilities,
which is what Clancy has decided to do as his computer points out to him.
Master it's become clear to me that you've been
doing mini my life.
If the show were merely to stop here,
we'd be forced to call dumb on this delightfully bizarre series.
Getting half of Buddhism right at the expense of the other half is not in
philosophical terms. Cool, but this show doesn't stop there.
Instead it explores how the pure universal truth approach to life does not
qualify as enlightenment. On the contrary,
it creates very real harm throughout much of the series Clancy's distain for the
material world keeps coming back to bite him in the early on.
We learned that Clancy's dismissive attitude towards humdrum.
Everyday life has begun to affect his relationships. For instance,
he is funding his face cast ambitions with money borrowed from his sister who
explicitly told him not to blow it on a multi-verse simulator is that.
I stare out at this majestic scene. I can't help,
but think of my sister, Sarah,
he said, Nancy, I'll loan you this money,
but you have this time is not to spend it on a youth universe emulator.
Where's her attempts to call him, which rightfully her off.
Clancy. It's your sister. You need to call me back right now.
P doc, man. There's no reason that your face.
Or by repeatedly ignoring his computer's request for basic maintenance.
He winds up damaging.
Most of the world's in a simulator before he even gets the chance to visit them.
Due to operator error. There are no longer living things on this planet.
What about this one?
Avoidance doesn't help Clancy transcend the very real problems of his busted
computer broken family ties and a weak space cast in search of the ultimate
truth.
Clancy has forgotten the relative truths and nuisances of everyday existence,
which no matter how much Iowasca you chug have a funny way of hanging around
until you actually do something about them.
When Clancy's sister finally gets through to him,
she explains that she doesn't even care about the money.
I love you. And if this is about the money, you don't need to pay me back.
She's just worried about her brother and how his refusal to face up to his role
in the world is hurting him.
This confrontation with the real world puts an unprepared Clancy and a full-on
sweaty panic attack,
which he follows with an angry outburst against the one person who cares enough
to check up on him.
Voicemail message, not received. Clearly.
Lancey isn't finding lasting peace and happiness from taking refuge in the
platitudes around ultimate truth, favored by hermits Bernie Mann, attendees,
and Jetta to achieve what we might call real enlightenment within a Buddhist
framework, sentience beings like Clancy,
and like us also have to come to terms with the painful sometimes downright
nasty facts of physical existence. And to do that,
we need to look at zombies no seriously in his book,
Dharma of the dead scholar,
Christopher M Mormon explore some of the parallels between zombie fiction and
Buddhism particularly important for our purposes.
He demonstrates how your typical glass eyes zombie wandering around in a stupor
can serve as a model for one of the potential pitfalls of meditation practice,
the deliberate cultivation of a pleasantly numb translate state of being devoid
of mindful attention, fictional zombies. In other words,
can represent one of the very real dangers of sloppy or misdirected
spirituality.
Zombies can be a metaphor for those practitioners of a given tradition who try
their damnedest to paper over the difficulties of relative existence with
ultimate truths about God, the universe, or whatever else is in that pamphlet.
They're shoving at your face from the Dalai Lama's point of view.
And this kind of zombie Zen existence would seem to stand in stark contrast to
the real goal of meditation.
Cultivating a moment to moment engagement with the present.
Also known as mindfulness in describing the difference between helpful practice
and self-imposed Zomba vacation Mormon also notes,
a parallel between core tenants of Buddhism and philosopher Martin Heidegger's
concept of design design is Heidegger's term for the uniquely human experience
of existence in describing the parallels between this thinking in Buddhism.
Mormon contends that according to Heidegger,
the authentic self is that which acknowledges its own mortality and incorporates
it.
The inauthentic self is one that denies death and fleas it here design sounds of
much like the Buddhist and not a different perspective on selfhood that
acknowledges the truth of its impermanence.
So what does that mean for our favorite space?
Castor put simply Clancy can laser focus on the ultimate truth.
Rhapsodize about phenomenological field and be a Dick to his sister,
as much as he pleases,
but doing those things will not help him become an authentic self like everyone
else in the universe, Clancy is in a nada, a not self,
which is to say a being subject to change, including discomfort and eventual.
Non-existence authentic.
Living follows not from a narrow emphasis on the wonderful things in life,
its beauty and pattern for instance,
but from an ongoing acceptance and integration of it, fear aspects such as pain,
violence, and death,
which is not to say that Buddhism is all doom and gloom far from it through his
interview subjects,
Clancy comes to realize that a worldview which integrates both a love of life
and a deep awareness of death is the gateway to a precious mode of being,
which he could never access through his space cast alone. In other words,
he starts to care about the world outside his simulator as a valuable part of
existence in and of itself over the course of his journey,
he comes to accept the at first glance contradictory notion that struggling with
life's hardships can bring immense pain,
but can also bring a profound piece that isn't so affected by the ups and downs
of the multi-verse. For example,
during one of Trussell slash Clancy's podcast interviews, Buddhist teacher,
Trudy Goodman rides through a graveyard while explaining.
Time of death is uncertain. But death is certain.
If we really got that,
we would have fewer of the kind of moments where we regret having wasted
our time or somebody else's. And it's so precious.
And just as horrible brutal as the world can be. It's gorgeous and exquisite.
I mean, it really hits home for Clancy.
When the multi-verse simulator brings him in contact with his mother voiced by
Duncan Trussell's real life.
Mom Deneen fended who passed away of cancer in 2013 as part of a
scene in which Clancy and his mom undergo a full life,
death and rebirth together. Deneen explains how she's holding up so well,
despite her diagnosis.
Look better now than I ever have is because I am more fully living,
right? Because I'm living and dying consciously, simultaneously,
I'm holding both.
In a similar way.
Clancy finally arrives at a degree of authenticity by dropping his pretensions
and learning to engage in his own life mess and all.
Even though your life is out of tune,
you can still sing along with it and it's better to
be you and out of tune than acting like someone else
too is found in life, man.
So put it another way. Clancy learns to embody both the ultimate truth.
He's so stoked about and the relative truth that the Dalai Lama or Heidegger
would argue is so vital to human existence.
We see his new awareness play out in the final moments of the series.
When a radon Clancy's unlicensed simulation farm ends with Clancy and his dog
diving all the way into the simulator to escape the FET moments later,
Clancy winds up on a bus,
surrounded by the people he's interviewed throughout the series.
This is a situation that ultimate truth Clancy could dissect for hours.
Is this the afterlife? Is he still in the simulator?
What the ever-loving is going on with the driver playing the spoons.
But instead we see Clancy experience a real moment of awareness and
clarity.
After walking to the back of the bus Clancy half-heartedly starts to interview a
stranger. You mind.
Am I dead.
Only to realize that something way more important than the space cast is
happening right in front of him. The man in the robe turns out to be rom Doss,
a practitioner of Eastern meditation techniques,
and one of Trussell's heroes who answers Clancy's questions by saying,
just be here. In other words,
Clancy rides off into eternity with the knowledge that a more specific answer to
his question,
doesn't really matter if and when the bus reaches its final destination,
whatever's waiting at the end can take care of itself.
What's really important right now is focusing his attention on every precious
moment. And that seems way closer to whatever real enlightenment looks like,
which is why graveyard penis not withstanding the series earns a solid
deep from us. So what do you think wisecrack?
And we oversold this cookie cartoon or is it even more brilliant than we're
giving it credit for it?
Let us know in the comments below and be sure to subscribe and ring that bell
big, thanks to our patrons for supporting the channel and our podcast.
Thanks for watching guys.
[Inaudible].